[Musique]
marcel c'est la haye bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes candidat respect dans le
nord dans la circonscription est le
numéro 2 alors respect pour résistance s
poids émancipation vous avez été
candidat aux élections à la 7e et qu'est
ce qui vous motive aujourd'hui mais nous
sommes dans une continuité du combat
alors je voulais quand même rappeler que
c'est marseillais et jacques attali qui
sont les candidats du mouvement social
si votre suppléante respect absolument
nous sommes dans une quantité de combat
il y a selon nous trois urgences
auxquelles il faut répondre nous battons
donc pour il prend en compte l'urgence
sociale
l'urgence démocratique et l'urgence
écologique donc c'est pour ça que nous
sommes candidats pour la représentation
des intérêts des classes populaires à la
fois de martinique mais de france
également et de toutes les populations
les couches populaires des colonies sous
administration française à l'horizon
social qu'est ce que vous entendez
période l'urgence sociale nous avons
d'abord un bilan il faut regarder le
bilan de celui qui a été à la présidence
on peut le résumer en parlant de
maltraitance salariale à la fois dans le
public et dans le privé le développement
de la précarité et de l'art et de la
pauvreté nous nous voulons avancer des
revendications pour réduire pour éviter
l'aggravation de niveau de vie des gens
et que par conséquent nous nous c'est
normal donc de demander l'augmentation
de tous les minima sociaux
l'augmentation de tous les salaires et
la prise en compte de cette inflation en
prenant sous les profits de ceux qui ont
profité des des exonérations sociales de
tout et patronales durant près de 10
2010 and année donc il de l'argent il y
en a et donc l'interdiction des
licenciements
le développement des services publics
donc ce sont des éléments qui te
permettent de ne pas éviter
l'aggravation de la situation le pouvoir
d'achat sur ce thème central de cette
campagne pour vous le pouvoir d'achat
n'est pas le sait la lutte contre le
système de la profitation qui sera le
donc nous sommes en train de nous battre
contre les effets du système de la
domination de la profitation les effets
de sa effectivement c'est le pouvoir
d'achat par conséquent nous battons pour
que les préserver le niveau de vie de
cette catégorie de la population vous
présentez comme une candidature des
colonials qu'est ce que ça veut dire ben
ça veut dire le saumon nous
reconnaissons faut d'abord reconnaître
que la question des colonials se pose en
situation coloniale nous sommes dans un
pays dominé nous appartenons de fait à
une entité dans les frontières sont en
europe et qui a également des frontières
en dans l'océan pacifique dans l'océan
indien en guyane et en martinique aux
antilles n'a la caraïbe en termes de
géopolitique long et biais dans l'empiré
français donc la question de notre
devenir de notre destin est aussi posée
pendant ces élections deuxième urgence
pour vous le délogeant démocratique si
oui c'est ti jean démocratique nous
venons d'évoquer cette question parce
que nous pensons que les institutions
telles que fonctionne aujourd'hui depuis
la naissance de cette 5ème république
elles ne sont pas adaptées elle exclut
au lieu d'intégrer ne sont pas
intégrative elles sont pas incluses yves
depas conséquent nous voulons poser la
question de la des élections à la
proportionnelle dans tous les élections
dans toutes les institutions et
deuxièmement la question qui est attaché
la question de la révocabilité des élus
les oui mais ce qu'il faut aussi aller
plus loin pour les électeurs resterait
le vote obligatoire par exemple nous
sommes banao des loques 6 le vote sept
doigts on ne peut pas imposer de voir si
c'est un doigt non non il faut
s'interroger sous lé phénomène de
l'abstention différemment et non pas les
poser en termes de devoir un thème de
moralisation il faut commencer interrogé
que quelles pistes alors il faut
attention
l'abstention a plusieurs causes bien
entendu mais ça va prendre du temps à
expliquer tout ça parce que les choses
sont complexes mais nous pensons que
s'il n'y a pas un désir d'aller voter
l'institutionnel pas à créer ce désir
d'aller voter donc les phénomènes de
l'abstention sont comme on dit
généralement le résultat de
l'insuffisance de systèmes impliquer les
citoyens et pommes et j'ajoute on a fait
quoi aux gens pendant quarante ans que
la voie électorale c'était la voix pour
changer ses conditions et les gens voter
on a demandé aux gens tout le
systématiquement de voter et on
travaille pour vous on a cultivé la
passivité pendant 40 ans de politique
ici en martinique et ailleurs et donc
les gens sont déçus normalement en moins
de 15 secondes
dernier point c'est l'écologie qu'est le
tempo lgv le point fort sur ce thème de
l'écologie la question de l'écologie
c'est la matrice à travers laquelle tous
les sujets doivent être abordés
diallo que nous avons maintenant les
rapports du giec qui dit très
concrètement ce qu'il faut faire et le
rapport du giec dit très concrètement il
faut changer le modèle économique
changer le modèle social si on veut
avoir une planète habitable marcel c'est
là j'ouvre merci merci c'est moi qui
vous remercie
[Musique]